vamos a aprender un poquito de
sucesiones y series bueno una sucesión
es simplemente un montón de números que
están acomodados en algún orden por
ejemplo en la sucesión dificilísima es
1234 creo que desde el punto verdad y
luego que es una serie pues una serie la
podemos pensar como la suma de los
elementos de una sucesión entonces por
ejemplo la serie aritmética sería pues
la suma de estos elementos de acá es
decir la pondríamos como uno más dos más
tres más y así sucesivamente hasta
digamos cierto número n esto de aquí se
le llama la serie aritmética la serie
me metí acá hasta ahorita nada
sofisticado verdad ahora antes de que
avancemos quiero introducir un poquito
de notación para representar este tipo
de sumas sin tener que escribir todos
los términos o bien sin tener que poner
puntos suspensivos va esta anotación se
llama la anotación de sigma ok lo que
voy a hacer es poner esta letra de aquí
ésta es una sigma es una letra griega y
es una sigma mayúscula entonces cómo le
hacemos para pasar esta anotación de
sigma pues lo que tenemos que hacer es
decir que vamos a sumar entonces sumemos
muchas casas está acá es una variable
arbitraria y vamos a empezar en acá
igual a 1 y recorrerlo uno por uno así
hasta llegar a n sale entonces esto de
aquí es exactamente lo mismo que poner
uno y luego su marca igualados y luego
su marca igual a 3 y así sucesivamente
hasta que cada es igual a n
1 y finalmente que k es igual a n ok
entonces esto de aquí
la anotación de sigma para la serie
aritmética mba
antes de seguir creo que es un buen
momento para aprender un poco más acerca
de la serie aritmética nos vamos a
enfocar en esta y también en la serie
geométrica porque son las dos que busque
ves más frecuentemente vale entonces una
vez que lleguemos a cálculo vas a ver
que pues tenemos otro tipo de serie
aunque es una serie de potencias pero
bueno por el momento vamos a jugar un
poquito con la serie aritmética verdad
entonces vamos a jugar con la serie
aritmética y déjame empezar por aquí
entonces llamemos ese a la suma a la
suma desde acá igual a uno hasta n bk es
decir a la suma de 12 más 3 más está
tratada
hasta n 1 más m
ok ahora bueno siguen la corriente
tantito voy a volver a escribir ese
entonces voy a poner ese igual a pero
ahora la voy a escribir al revés es más
o menos intuitivo verdad si cambiamos el
orden de los factores no nos debería
afectar el resultado bueno si tenemos
una cantidad finita de sumandos pero
otra vez bueno no quiero confundirte voy
a escribir esto pero en orden inverso
entonces voy a poner n mas n menos uno
más en m2 más está tratada más dos más
uno ok es exactamente la misma suma solo
que en orden contrario ahora hice eso
por una razón porque ahora voy a sumar a
ambos lados de esta ecuación del lado
izquierdo ese más s me queda simplemente
12 ese y del lado derecho me queda esta
suma más de esta suma ahora el chiste es
que esto debe de tener un truco verdad
lo escribí así para que podamos hacer
alguna cosa pues un poco más pues
creativa y así entonces vamos a sumar
mejor por columna verdad en vez de sumar
todo
vamos a sumar core por columnas entonces
vamos a sumar 2 con n menos 13 con n 2 y
así sucesivamente déjame marcar los los
términos que vamos a sumar 2 con n 13
con en el -2 a lo mejor se avista que va
todo esto verdad y esto hasta llegar
hasta n con una que sucede cuando
sumamos así cuando esté n 1 pues eso es
n 1 ahora cuánto es 2 + n 1 pues eso
otra vez es n 1 n más uno que pasa aquí
tres más n 2
si adivinaste es otra vez en de más uno
más está tratada y podemos seguir
haciendo esto hasta en 12 perdón esto
aquí es más en demás uno más y contraste
más uno y psn uno ok
vale entonces mi pregunta es cuántas
veces apareció aquí n 1 pues nos vamos
aquí arriba y vemos que son n cada n 1
corresponde a uno de los sumandos de
aquí arriba entonces hay n de estos y
podemos reescribir esta expresión como
n por n 1
ay qué bonito fíjate entonces dos veces
la suma es igual a n por n 1 de modo que
podemos dividir ambos lados en 2 y tener
que s es igual a n por n más uno
dividido entre 2 va ahora porque estoy
aquí está tan padre o bien porque está
interesante número uno pues encontramos
una forma de que esta anotación de sigma
la simplificamos a esta cosa a una
fórmula cerrada entonces a ver aquí le
pongo n que le pongo de acá igual a uno
hasta n de cada y lo que puedes hacer es
puedes hacer trucos de fiesta con esto
déjame te enseño a qué me refiero a ver
le voy a poner aquí tridimensional que
estoy haciendo no no haber invertir
colores ajá entonces que así trucos de
fiesta
imagínate que llegas con alguien y dices
que te puedo sumar los números de 1 a
100 así en un instante entonces cómo le
hagas para hacer esto pues sumas
a ver déjame poner esto voy a poner otra
variable digamos b igual a 1 breve hasta
hasta 100 ok y entonces estoy aquí es la
suma desde 1 a 100 y ya descubrimos la
fórmula para esto estoy aquí simplemente
es 100 x 101 dividido entre 2 y esta
multiplicación ya está súper fácil
cuánto es 100% 1 eso es 101 con dos
ceros y eso dividido entre 2 y esta
división está fácil simplemente es 5.050
listo eso ya está muy padre en vez de
hacer 1 2 3 4 a mano y así hasta 98 99 y
100 simplemente pues pues pudimos
cambiar toda esta suma que nos puede
crear errores a una multiplicación de
una división va eso de ahí es igual a
5.000 50
ok pueden hacer algo todavía más
impresionante de hecho diez veces más
impresionante que para la suma de
números de uno a mil va entonces la
fórmula es n por n 1 entre 2 y tiene es
igual a 1.000 entonces la fórmula nos
quedaría 1000 x 1000 1 y eso dividido
entre 2 vale eso de ahí es igual a pues
hay que ponerle tres ceros a 1001 mil
ok un millón mil y eso de ahí tenemos
que dividirlo entre dos verdad entonces
le pongo por aquí así tengo que dividir
esta expresión un millón mil entre dos
ahí está ahora eso cuánto nos queda pues
cuánto es la mitad de mil la mitad de
miles quinientos y luego hay que sumarle
la mitad de un millón la mitad del
millones 500 mil entonces nos quedan 500
mil 500
eso está padrísimo eso te hubiera tomado
muchísimo verdad hacerlo a mano si
hubieras hecho las mil sumas o más
hubiera tomado muchísimo tiempo pero
ahora ya lo hicimos súper rápido vale
esto de aquí es la serie de aritmética
pero ahora vamos a pasar a otra serie
típica que te vas a encontrar a cada
rato de hecho te la vas a encontrar pues
en cosas de finanzas y en cosas de
biología en cosas de crecimiento de
población hay un montón de lugares en
donde se aparece en la ciencia vale esta
de aquí se llama la serie geométrica
entonces la serie geométrica
esencialmente es tomar x no voy a ser
generalmente entonces voy a tomar una
variable x no mejor no voy a poner x voy
a tomar otro número
digamos voy a llamarle a ver voy a poner
la suma mejor lo escribo pues para no
decir tantas cosas voy a sumar al acá y
lo que voy a mover no es sino acá
entonces voy a poner desde acá igual a 0
hasta acá igual a n ok eso qué quiere
decir eso quiere decir a la 0 cuando cae
0 más a la 1
más al cuadrado más al cubo más tratada
trata más a la n-1 más a la más más a la
n2 entonces esto de aquí se le llama una
serie geométrica y se llama así porque
este tipo de crecimiento en el cual
vamos aumentando el exponente se le
llama geométrico o exponencial cómo le
hacemos para sumar estos términos bueno
vamos a ver si podemos hacer un truco
similar ahora vamos a tener que si se
puede pero hay que hacer un paso
adicional vamos a llamarle ese a la suma
entonces ese va a ser igual a esto a la
suma desde acá igual a cero hasta n de
aa la k es decir s es igual a la cero
más a la 1 más al cuadrado más y así
sucesivamente hasta a la enee menos uno
más aa la n 2
ok entonces ahora vamos a definir otra
suma pero pero sabes que ahorita ya se
me está acabando el tiempo mejor lo
hacemos en el próximo vídeo hasta pronto